i've been doing data engineering for a  while and looking to put that stamp of  approval on my resume any suggestions  have you considered the google cloud  professional data engineer certification  it is  pretty solid line item on the resume  plus it acts as a solid proof that you  can design build  operationalize secure and even monitor  those data processing systems  what is the test like it's a two hour  multiple choice exam that tests you on  building managing data processing  pipelines at scale in the cloud this is  great thank you so much any advice on  where to start  there are tons of training resources  from sample questions to hands-on labs  and on-demand courses just check them  out